Hollywood came to the nation's capital
this week to premiere the first feature
film on the life of an American icon
Harriet based on the life of Harriet
Tubman open to an enthusiastic crowd in
the very place that's home to some of
her precious possessions the Smithsonian
National Museum of african-american
history and culture
Harriet speaks to truths rarely shared
about Tubman and her journey from
slavery to freedom during a star-studded
red carpet she did the impossible on
some of America's most hallowed ground
the makers of Harriet shared their
inspiration people Tony award-winner
Cynthia areevo plays Harriet Tubman but
for nearly three years the slave born
Araminta Ross came into focus through
the lens of director and co-writer Casey
lemons she accomplished so much just on
determination I mean she was illiterate
she could neither read nor write and yet
she was able to accomplish these really
amazing feats of courage this was
resistance you still see people trying
to create some fantasy about what
slavery was like and the people were
somehow content people wanted to escape
they're willing to risk their lives led
through the Underground Railroad the
network of secret routes and safe houses
that brought slaves to the north she
then became one of its most successful
conductors rescuing more than 300 people
before the Civil War ready some 700
after it started we can go this way does
danger and while her actions were heroic
Lemmon says her motivation was something
more basic one thing we know about
Harriet she was motivated by love
I come again bring on a view to freedom
she was motivated by love of her husband
love of her family and really feeling
like if she was free they should be too
we caught up with lemons and her own
family at the Lenox coffee shop in
Harlem it's a family affair which it
makes it so good both are husband
director producer Von D Curtis Hall and
her son Henry hunter hall star in the
movie I mean did you have it in your
mind all three of you we went in Hunter
actually came in was teasing me leaning
over my shoulders I was writing going
doesn't here yet have a sidekick in fact
she did a Union Army spy named Walter
ploughing but lemons placed him much
earlier in Tubman's life names what why
should I trust you Walter most folks
definition that it was such a great care
and I was like oh god I need to play
this was that an uphill battle for you
winning over your mom I mean moms was
definitely like don't mess up my movie
maybe nobody notice you go maybe you
sneak back home dealing a little bit Oh
Von D Curtis Hall is the Reverend Samuel
Greene an ally of runaway slaves
including Tubman herself he's not what
he seems at first was that hard to kind
of play that do duplicity
I don't think about about reven greed
for me to see that that you think this
and you he turns out to be such an
integral part of the Underground
Railroad
Harriet welcome to the underground world
what does it like to work with him and
what's it like to work for her work for
her yeah I really like working for her
because she's so specific with her with
her vision sometimes I feel like a prop
but sometimes sometimes you know it's
you she really gives you the opportunity
to sort of stretch shot on-location in
Virginia not in Tubman's native state of
Maryland Lemmons claims cast and crew
alike still felt an otherworldly
connection we shot on plantations where
there have been a thousand slaves and
you could feel it you could feel it in
the air and in the ground but it wasn't
a terrible thing it was a celebration of
the people that had lived and worked and
loved and died there somehow you could
feel their strength so being cold and
wet in the woods we just got a little
tiny taste of what it must have been
like to be alone with no shelter hiding
30 years in the business
lemons has really done it all writing
producing selectors handwriting even
acting in such blockbusters as Silence
of the Lambs how do you kill someone but
it was her directorial debut in the 1997
film Eve's Bayou that earned her
critical and commercial success still it
didn't bring an onslaught of
opportunities in the director's chair
Harriet is her fifth directing credit in
just over 20 years how did you sell it
well we sold it on the idea of Harriet
Tubman as a young kind of action hero
which was inherent to the story wasn't
imposed on it because that's what she
was you know you got lucky Harriet and
there's nothing more you can do don't
you tell me what I can do I made it this
far mom God was watching but my feet was
my home running bleeding climbing nearly
drowned nothing to eat for days and days
man I made it for this generation
what should Harriet mean fighting apathy
I mean I I find that there's a lot about
but the endless generation and I
understand because of the problems of
the world seems so insurmountable
I understand you just want to put your
head down my favorite Harriet Tubman
quote she said I prayed to God to make
me strong enough to fight and that's
what I pray for ever since and that's
what I think we need we have to fight
for our country we have to fight for the
planet we have to fight for the future
we have to fight for our children we
have to fight for our rights we have a
lot of fights and so yeah pray to God to
make you strong enough to fight now
consider this
you know Harriet Tubman was just 5 feet
2 inches tall she was a spy she was a
nurse she was a cook and she was a
fighter in the Civil War she fought for
women's suffrage but this I love you
know she was married
before she ran away right and she ended
up by the end of her life to be married
she married to a man
22 years her junior so here she is dying
at the age of 91 and her last words were
I go to prepare a place for you this
movie comes out November 1st so I want
both of you yeah it really is an
important film it looks amazing I love
the story behind it and women's to her
family that part of directing it's crazy
because I met Lemmons 30 years ago we
were extras in a movie together five
heartbeats we learned that her cousin my
cousin is her best friend it was the
craziest gracious the separation degree
Miller that's full disclosure sorry sons
the lens yeah